the world health organization warns a
wide-ranging postcovid 19 crisis is
coming the lingering effects of a
syndrome called long covid threaten to
transform the lives of patients the
global health care system and the world
economy there's a post-viral syndrome
very poorly understood
very difficult to track many many people
affected a lot of unknowns about how
long people will go on and have
continued symptoms and signs
many different hundreds of different
symptoms have been documented the who
says in the first two years of the
pandemic more than 17 million people in
europe alone have struggled with effects
lasting three months or longer that's
300 percent higher than earlier
estimates globally washington university
school of medicine puts that figure at
145 million the group says 10 to 20
percent of patients develop long covet
symptoms include shortness of breath
fatigue with bodily pain and mood swings
and cognitive problems such as confusion
forgetfulness and an inability to focus
ann lee who chairs the network
long-covered europe knows how that feels
she's still experiencing some of the
effects after contracting the virus in
march of 2020 women are twice as likely
to suffer from the syndrome the
organization says and the risk increases
dramatically in severe cases that
require hospitalization the wh says long
covet will affect millions more patients
and the bottom lines of companies and
economies it warns that governments and
health systems will need to invest in
treatments and employers will need to
make special allowances for workers
debilitated by long-term covet
making that task even more difficult is
a staffing shortage we found that one
out of three in the 40 countries that
have data have a very rapidly aging
health workforce and we find that
up to 40 percent of their medical
doctors in these countries are aged over
55 so that's a ticking time bomb as the
outbreak appears to be moving past its
most serious phase long covid and the
worker shortage suggest a new wave of
post-pandemic problems has already begun
john hendren al jazeera tel aviv